tonight speaker Scott kildall is an
artist he's a computer scientist he's
somebody who has worked with some of
with with large tech companies with with
with technological tools that are that
are cutting edge and we're gonna not
only learn about his work tonight but
we're gonna learn about a process and
the way that as he's working today with
scientists at SETI as he's worked with
technology at Autodesk and other
projects over the years how he brings
art thinking into the picture with
technologists and scientists so please
give a big round of applause first Scott
now great hi everyone and I just want to
thank Michael n for all the hard work
you've done in making me comfortable
here this is the long now foundation
does it right for their speakers they
make everyone feel super comfortable in
the space and they offer me anything
I've wanted and they have a great media
team to to support me so I feel really
lucky in that I'm what's called a new
media artist and it's sort of a funny
term because it's not defined by the
media I work and it's not defined by
material like painting or sculpture but
rather by time itself and so that means
I work with new materials like 3d
printing interactive media internet
media and that sort of thing and this
gives me a lot of latitude to work with
new technologies and incorporate old
ones as well so I'm gonna go back a
little ways here honoree Bergson is
probably the most famous philosopher
you've never heard of and he was super
popular in the turn of the 19th century
and was influential in the work on
thinking about models of time and he did
a lot of work in thinking about the
conundrum at the time or the model of
perception was the perception in memory
in 1892 1900s were thought of one and
the same thing so you sort of perceive
into the future as well as perceive into
the past
and this presented a lot of problems for
Burks and he looked at the current model
of time then which is very similar to
the common model of time now which is
that you have the future on one side in
the past on the other and then you have
this infinitely small slice of the
present moment and you couldn't
reconcile that because the present
moment if you think about it harder and
harder to think about it we probably did
this when we were little kids the more
it becomes into this sort of Zeno's
paradox where the present moment doesn't
seem to really exist and in mulling over
this present moment problem he started
working on this new model of time and he
published a book in a treatise in 1896
called matter of memory in which he came
up with this three-part model of time
and it's this three-part model of time
they think is one that I've been working
with and thinking about in terms of
future thinking and some of the projects
that been done looking at and so this is
my adapted model of the Brooks timing
and model of time I kind of cut through
a lot of its philosophical language
because it's a little bit hard to
decipher in today's parlance so in the
Brookstone Ian model of time you have
the future so these are things that like
vacations you might be planning things
are going to be happening a week from
now maybe tomorrow and things in the
past long-term memories and Bergson was
really thinking more about the
psychological aspects of time as opposed
to the Einstein Ian relativistic time
problems so I think you know things are
happening in the brain and expanded
present are things that are happening
just an immediate future your sense of
anticipation and also sloughing off the
current events as they happen so
expanding that window into like a bubble
so if you think about things that are
happening tonight
I just been talking for just a couple of
minutes now and we're definitely in that
still expanded presence of time and this
burg Sounion idea of this expansion of
time the subjective present has been
affirmed by neuroscientists such as
David Eagleman who talks about
subjective time in our own brains and so
each of our own brains has its own
conception of the present because our
brain acts kind of like a clock its own
clocking mechanism where it gets
reactions from our fingertips or
years our eyes that are offering at
different time scales and synchronizes
them into one sort of clock for our own
brains and so each one of us is
operating our own subjective present
time space and so this is always kind of
the way with artists and philosophers
they often precede the work of
scientists they come up with these you
know crazy ideas and oftentimes in
language that's hard to understand and
then years decades later a scientist
will affirm the artistic and
philosophical discoveries and so the
structure for the talk tonight is I'm
going to be presenting about four
different projects and Inter woven with
some of the ideas about our thinking and
time models along the way the first
project and they did a thing we're
talking about for the evening is one
called tweets in space this is a
collaboration with my colleague
nathaniel stern he's a professor of
digital arts over the university of
wisconsin-milwaukee and i've collaborate
with him on a few different projects now
and the idea behind tweets in space and
this is a project that we did in 2012 so
it's a sum of the technology and physics
might have changed since then in terms
of exoplanet studies is that we want to
send Twitter messages to a nearby
habitable planet that might support
human-like biological life right and
that planet that we chose was GJ 667cc
and I was informed by Frank marchis the
astronomer at SETI
before the talk did that's still in the
habitable zone and they still might
support alien life so so and it's this
has some of the ideal conditions to
support life or so we think and there's
still a lot of unknowns but we just
chose this planet in particular and one
of the reasons we chose G chase except
7cc is that it's 22 light years away so
it's relatively close we didn't want to
send Twitter messages to something
that's a thousand light years away it
has to be close enough that we might be
able to get a response in this in my
lifetime and we build this as a
presentation at the Electronic
international symposium of electronic
art as eya at Albuquerque New Mexico in
2012 and so it was a 30 minute
performance and during those 30 minutes
and only those 30 minutes you could send
a Twitter tweet with the hashtag tweets
in space and and of course you could do
it anywhere in the world and we captured
this in this back-end Twitter bucket for
later transmission
and one of our ideas for for this
project what was was that we went to
have this be an uncreated bead we wanted
to have anyone could tweet about
anything they wanted and we would
transmit it later and this is what the
actual performance the physical
performance looked like this is a Isaiah
this is the balloon Museum in
Albuquerque we had about a hundred
people there in physical space and of
course we had people in virtual space so
they could log onto the website and see
the tweets similar what you saw a minute
ago scrolling live through the screen
and this was the double projection
animation software I wrote where what
would happen is that let's see if this
works what happens the Twitter messages
would come up the screen here and in
life time in real time and then beam
from this little satellite dishes into
the spaceship and fly off into space so
we had a AV performance as well and this
was one of the few instances where you
have a performance where you invite
people to actually bring out their
phones and participate although the
reality is we couldn't tell if people
were just on Facebook or Twitter and
essential to the success of this project
was to have a tactical media campaign as
well and so we reached out and developed
a press strategy and is up again getting
about 40 to 50 articles in mainstream
media articles in places such as the New
York Daily News Wired science and all
that media coverage about the project
made a hugely successful one we ended up
getting 1500 tweets in about 30 minutes
so it's almost a tweet a second which
was great we didn't know if I was gonna
work out we thought it might just be 50
of our 50 tweets from our friends but
when we got the wire science article we
knew that was going to work out pretty
well for us the transmission date was
about six weeks later and we transmitted
it from a satellite dish that we rented
out in Florida so it's a small to medium
dish so in theory you need like a large
listening dish to to hear the messages
and those were transmitted six weeks
later because s the time at which GJ
667cc would be in the right spot so that
22 point one light years later it would
get this decayed radio message and this
was a worldwide perform
it's repurposed social media Twitter at
the time wasn't quite the sort of hot
political issue it is now our hot
political item and like I said we it was
an uncreated unfiltered set of tweets
though we were a little bit worried we
might get some hate hate tweets in there
but this was 2012 it's those kind leur
gentler times and we didn't yeah and we
did we didn't get any of that so that
was that was good that was good know
nothing about nothing nothing hateful we
did get a lot of really nice ones that
are like high alien neighbors does it
here's us here on earth ones of love so
people from all over the world wishing
love and spreading that that kind of
message a lot of them in different
languages so for some reason I mean
Mandarin doesn't surprise me but there's
a lot of Portuguese for some reason so I
guess there must have been some
Portuguese media people of course asking
like what color people are green or blue
this is a classic one we do Pez right
and there were also a lot of popular
cultural references the one that
surprised me the most was this this kind
of sentiment people who were apologizing
on behalf of the poor behavior of human
beings and there was a lot of people who
said like you know we've done a lot of
bad things but we're still a good race
of people are please forgive us come
visit us anyways and so what the tweets
the space project did was looking at
this kind of sort of point of here and
now was to expand that timeframe of that
at that point of now to make it a little
further because now the artwork is
5-year light-years away from us in this
decaying orbit but that's where the
artwork is and it also opened up that
sense of space as in this like larger
spatial point of view and the extension
of the artwork is going to be 22 years
into the future so technically it
doesn't exist once it hits the planet
which is an odd way to think about
artwork but that's the way I think about
it and so I'm gonna have a few
propositions for the evening the first
one is that art thinking allows us to
expand our notions of space and time and
our thinking is a methodology by which
artists developed
work as a methodology I've researched
and and developed and and so just to
state the case that this is my
methodology I think it applies to a lot
of other artists I'm going to propose
that it's a valid methodology for
creating artwork and one the artist
views but first of all I want to talk
about design thinking which is where
this came out of so design thinking is I
entered the popular lexicon it's this
five-step process that was really
pioneered and by the d.school here at
Stanford and and the first step is this
empathize step and that's one where
you're learning about the audience for
which you're developing the design work
so it kind of makes sense it's a user
centred approach and the second step is
defining the problem and so what you're
doing is figuring out what your users
might want and then sort of bounding the
scope of the problem in the first two
steps and that's the the first two steps
of the design thinking process now the
art thinking methodology has a different
sort of five step process that developed
I do want to acknowledge some of the
various thinkers I had been reading and
researching over the years to get to
this point and this is Amy Whittaker
she's written about her version of art
thinking and but she's written about
some really interesting ideas about
having studio time and about failure
modes I think had been really
influential for me also John Maeda who
is a luminary and and designer and
thinker who has amazing ideas and one of
my favorite is this quote which he says
when people say I don't get art that
means artists working but it art art is
supposed to be confusing they're
supposed to go into a gallery or museum
and kind of wonder like what is you're
seeing is supposed to ask you questions
and make you wonder why you're there
make you feel uneasy not provide easy
answers and this isn't to say that the
writing about art isn't problematic
because they're writing about artists
often terrible like we've all walked
into museum spaces not interested what
the text is about but to go into an art
space and see something that is is
confusing is the norm and so this is the
five step are thinking diagram that I've
been working on and so it goes through
the first step here is an inquiry step
and this starts with some sort of
observation some sort of question maybe
an experiment
Tyrael just some sort of point of
curiosity and and and so this is a for
me I have an idea book and all my all my
ideas go into that idea book the only
thing that's kind of a valid inquiry
will go in there so some really bad
stuff and really good stuff and really
mediocre stuff I'd like to say my art
idea book with something like this but
it's actually just an Evernote document
so I'm gonna share with you three three
of my bad art ideas and you're welcome
to borrow any of them that's a bad idea
number one is to bury 3d printed fake
fossils for future generations so
unicorn skulls fake animals I'm not
gonna do this anyone else wants to do it
you can you don't have to credit me bad
idea number two RGB war it's a iPhone
Android app so you choose it game red
green or blue and repeatedly press that
color and get people to tap and take
over territory so not only is it a bad
idea it's like a socially useless idea
just a waste of time bad idea number
three is EU gasm so you wear an EEG
headset and report people's orgasms and
you sort of create like a sort of
pleasure signature for each person and
some sort of data visualization I
thought this would be well we'll just
let it go at that and so the next the
next stage after this inquiry stage is
kind of boosting some of these ideas out
the idea book into the experimentation
stage and this is the most fun part of
any project or any sort of art work it
doesn't really exist as a project at
this point you're just kind of kind of
[ __ ] around and just throwing stuff
at the wall seeing what happens for
tweets in space this meant building
these janky little receivers and then
Arduino and sending the messages back
and forth and kind of thinking about
protocols and messaging systems and just
using our imaginations and having fun
with the project the next the third
phase is the shaping phase and this is
where you're sort of bringing all the
different pieces and parts into a
cohesive kind of whole and this is where
the project really becomes like like a
form that you can work with us for
tweets in space this was where we
realized that we needed a messaging
system but also some sort of media
strategy at the
time that really was two arms of the
same project up to that point we hadn't
thought about the media that much and we
thought oh my gosh was a tactical media
project of course like we need publicity
to make this out this project work and
the fourth stage is refinement and to
distinguish that from shaping it it's
like imagining have this like sort of
blob of an artistic project that's a
cohesive whole refining it you're just
smoothing out the edges and you're
conceptually tightening up and if you
don't go through this refinement stage
you end up with this artwork that
doesn't quite work in a gallery space
for us so for tweets and space what that
meant is that we were going through and
thinking about how to write the text
developing the press list like coming up
with talking to physicists and figuring
out the exact parameters of the
messaging system and really kind of
making it to a cohesive whole and the
last phase is a showing the artwork
phase and this is an important phase
because if you don't show the artwork
you never come into a space where you
get critical feedback and it's that
critical feedback that really completes
the work making yourself feel vulnerable
actually thinking about the display
elements and this is the final part
where you're thinking about how it's
going to be presented and and with that
showing phase lets you do is it also let
you come back to your point of inquiry
right so after you show it you get more
questions and you can come back and
develop the work further and make more
work and so this art thinking model
nowhere in there are we really thinking
about except for slightly at the very
end but we're not really thinking about
these bounded approaches that you just
haven't designed thinking they're
open-ended approaches you start with
inquiry and experiment and then you sort
of shape this form but starts with this
open-ended approach an unbounded
approach and this is how our just
approach their artwork in my experience
okay so proposition number two for the
evening
artists act as generalists and this is
one thing I love about making work is
that I can work on projects where I can
collaborate with not only scientists but
also engineers other thinkers all over
the place so typically I'll make between
one and five projects a year and over
the course of 15 years that amounts to a
lot of different projects this is one
called waterworks which I did as a
creative code fellowship between
Autodesk stamen design and gray area
arts which is a local arts organization
and in this process in this project what
I did was I decided to make a physical
data visualization of the water
infrastructure of San Francisco so all
the pipes the networks of pipes
underneath our feet and the whole idea
there was to somehow make visible the
invisible so bring up something from
that we don't see and bring it up to our
physical space and so as playing the
role of a water detective Data Miner and
that's still from Chinatown for those of
you don't recognize it and and and and
unlike tweets in space where I played
the role of an amateur astronomer I got
to be a whole nother person for this
project and and this is this amazing
gift I feel like artists have is the
ability to go into different kinds of
modalities and and play with entirely
different dialogues and so my point of
inquiry for tweets and for water works
with this data set from the Department
of Public Works which was the data set
of 30,000 manholes and the chamber size
beneath each the volume with the chamber
underneath each manhole and that 30,000
pipes that connected each manhole in the
diameter of each pipes so you can
imagine for some of our data geek like
me this was just like amazing like oh my
gosh this is just such a cool data set
and what can I do with this data set and
this data set depicted the combined
wastewater system of San Francisco so
for San Francisco is different than
other California coastal cities and the
water from your toilets your showers and
the storm water all flow into the same
set of pipes and then they get piped out
to gravity-fed for the most part to the
two wastewater treatment plants on one
on the bay and one on the ocean and so
you know thinking about how to
experiment with making this project I
worked with kind of you know some
sketches of manholes this one is not
what I did but I kind of liked it and
trying to figure out what was beneath
our feet and what it actually looked
like and started working with 3d
printing over at Autodesk I had a chance
to work with their 3d printers and start
writing code that would generate these
models automatically instead of making
them by hand and and so it was after
that kind of process of iteration just
for a little while they realized that 3d
printing seemed to be the right form to
express this because
it could algorithmically generate this
model from data sets but also there's
something to sort of magical about 3d
printing that felt like is bringing it
up from the bottom of the earth into the
surface and so then I began to shape the
project and this involved brainstorming
with my mentors on the project in this
fellowship and thinking about the
various forms that could take and I did
a lot of work and the shaping process is
often involves most of the work in this
in this art thinking model and I wrote
code and open frameworks an open-source
C++ toolkit to model out the the
manholes in 3d space in virtual space so
this is the northern part of the city of
course natives in San Francisco will
recognize this as Golden Gate Park any
residents here this is I guess Buena
Vista Twin Peaks and you can see the
ridge lines of the city and so this is
just the manhole data with some
elevations I put in there and then the
feedback I got from the mentors was to
geolocate this on some sort of map that
without a map it didn't really kind of
work and so I settled upon this this
laser-etched map making this at autodesk
with help from stamen design from the
mapping and this is just a section of
the downtown area you can see the piers
near the bay and that little piece at
four at top which is the bay bridge and
then i worked on the refinement step for
this process which involved really
honing the 3d geometry and coming up
with the exact area that I wanted to
print out and this is the export model
that I made you can see this section of
San Francisco so printing out the entire
3d sewer network would be too big for
even these large printers I was using
and so this is the final 3d model that I
exported from the code I wrote and then
finally preparing it for show which
meant all the detailed fabrication work
you know drilling out the holes mounting
it that's me in the shop and that's the
final piece there and so this these
fills here are accentuated by about
three times so that's like that make San
Francisco look like it's got super super
steep hills everywhere but I found that
if it's not accentuated that much it
doesn't really have that sort of like
doesn't really kind of hold
you were in the same way and you can't
really see the individual nodes here's
an upper upper view of the more brute I
like view of the model and here's a
close-up and with the close-up you can
start to see some really interesting
features this is Telegraph Hill over
here so you see this like sort of like
old node network of small manhole small
pipes
this is Kearney Street right there this
thoroughfare and you can also see the
pipes along the Embarcadero some really
thick stuff going on in here rink on
senator Moscone Center maybe and this
kind of grid like surface over here and
so it was interesting to present this
work and oh just the gray the light gray
or the pipes in the dark gray or the
manholes and so everything gets kind of
overlapped and mushed on top of each
other
and so one of the precepts I'm kind of
working with is that data somehow has
physical consequences so most data is is
presented oftentimes on the screen and
the screen is this odd sort of place to
look at data because the screen has its
intimacy about lack of intimacy because
the screen is this function of the
computer that we look at all the time
for just about everything everything
personal everything business and so
there's a certain distance that we have
from the screen but bring it into
physical space we can move around it and
look around it we can touch it we can
see it from different vantage points and
so it seems appropriate for me to create
data that is modeled physically and
that's really the crux of my practice
nowadays okay proposition number three
it's okay to appropriate the work of
artists okay I know this one's going to
get me in trouble
and I'll qualify it but but I think that
if you kind of come back to this model
like artists aren't really meant to
participate in the market in the first
place I mean maybe you sell some works
I'm sure that's that's part of the
market most artists have a lot of
trouble making it living doing that I
mean the markets not really there to
support artists in the first place and I
want to give you one example James
Turrell
so for those of you that aren't familiar
with James Terrell's work he is a like a
an amazing artist that works with light
and space have you ever seen any of this
installations you go there and you feel
the sense of like sublime sort of
spiritual at peace with the world and
and just works with your perception in
such ways that it was just somehow
magical
he's been doing this work for years and
years and he sort of pioneered that area
this is the video by Drake called
hotline bling which came out last year
and if you look at this video you'll see
that it really looks a lot like James
Terrell's work right like the changing
light sculpture was sort of minimal one
of the folks at Hyperallergic did a shot
by shot analysis of some of Drake's work
and and Terrell's work and so on the top
you see Drake's Drake's you know
installation on this video work in the
video and then Terrell's installations
below and Drake was asked about this and
and he actually said you know and
actually said she said you're a big
influence yeah you know I [ __ ] with
Tyrell he was a big influence on me and
then they asked Tyrell about it and
Tyrell said you know well he honored my
work you know I actually enjoyed it I
got a lot more attention since he got
involved and so so I kind of come back
to this proposition and that's why I
called a proposition and not a statement
it's okay to appropriate the work of
artists under a few conditions first of
all you need to recontextualize the work
which i believe is what dick Drake did
he presented a music video the music
kind of matched the form that he was
working with he reshot it so reaching
contextualizing work doesn't mean going
on someone's website and taking the jpeg
off there and printing out a quilt and
selling on Alibaba that's not really
recontextualizing it that's just
stealing it and also our just need to
have some sort of funding model right so
like taking work and appropriate from
some artists that's not even how it
doesn't mean something sort of living to
make their work and it's doing that on
the side it's not really fair to the
artist but if they had funding behind
them then they could participate in this
kind of economy where they could let
their ideas go more freely and finally
give them some sort of Nod of credit and
that is important not only to
acknowledge the artist but also to
dispel this creator myth that this idea
that we somehow get amazing ideas from
our own head and they're not born from
anywhere else to just acknowledge this
and create a lineage of thought and
culture and I think that kind of idea
that that I'm kind of mining here or
thinking about is that artists have need
to have this expanse of time and if
they're working with the exigencies of
the market and thinking about how to
make a living all the time they don't
have time to really think about those
long-term kind of thoughts and to work
in this artistic direction they're much
more
concerned with the immediate how to saw
my work how to find funding and don't
have that expanse of space to be
creative okay so proposition number four
artists have more in common with
scientists and designers this is the
scientific method which is something
that we probably learned in high school
and and and maybe the scientists know
that that there's a lot of similarities
between artists and scientists and their
methodology you start from points of
curiosity you go through this iterative
kind of experimentation process you're
not really thinking about user centric
design and thinking about these bounded
sort of problems and yeah and the other
the results are very different artists
are making like the specific object or
performance that might express a larger
idea and scientists are usually making
some sort of general theory or
abstraction but they're usually kind of
working the same kind of freeform
sort of thought process and this kind of
led me into working with scientists this
kind of similarity with other scientists
and this sort of we're of the same kind
of people and so currently I'm an artist
in residence with the SETI organization
SETI Institute and they were amazing
scientists there I go down there and I
talk to people who are thinking about
really weird stuff all the time and
asking the big questions of like why are
we here you know where did we come from
and I'm also doing the same thing I'm
thinking about really weird [ __ ] all the
time and asking myself the same
questions but but we're going about it
in completely different ways so for this
project stringfield's I worked with dr.
Peter Jenniskens who is an amazing
scientist he is one of the world's
experts on meteorites and meteors and so
he and he sort of when I got in there
explain what a strewn field is and so a
strewn field is what happens when an
asteroid comes into Earth's atmosphere
so for just to clarify asteroid is
floating a space a meteor is when it
enters the atmosphere instead you know
that ball of fire and a meteorite is the
shards on the ground and so so a stream
field when asteroid comes into Earth's
atmosphere comes so it may be thirty
thousand kilometers an hour it's
superfast it gets heated up really
quickly it slows down because he hits
atmosphere and they'll burst into
various chards sending meteorites
meteors all over the place and hitting
in the ground is spreading this field of
meteorites every
we're and it might be over as long as 30
kilometers that can be a huge distance
and that's Western field is that is that
meteorite kind of spread and and he's
worked with folks such as people in the
Sudan at this recent relatively recent
meteorite fall in 2008 he worked with
students there at the University of
Khartoum to map the meteorites out and
remember this is over like maybe 30
kilometers right in the sand and so he
had 100 volunteers and and they're all
it can you imagine them walking through
the sand for weeks picking up like this
and things this a meteorite is like now
but eventually he got the students got
pretty well trained it wasn't a
meteorite and they ended up producing
this amazing data set of of meteorite
stringfield's and you've current
technology they could geo locate each
one so you have a latitude longitude so
you have an XY and then you have a mass
a size for the meteorite so I could work
with those three points of data and my
inquiry point was how to make a physical
artwork from a string field so given the
stream field dataset what can I do with
it
um and I decided to use the water jet
machine at autodesk where I work now and
and the water jet machine is just this
amazing tool it's kind of like a like a
laser cutter with water it exudes a 55
thousand psi stream of water it can cut
through like anything it's crazy it can
cut through up to six inches thick of
steel and so what I thought about was
was using that kind of violence of the
water jet machine that that mirrored
this kinetic energy of the the asteroid
just this like huge pounding and and
etching but not piercing into stone and
stone makes sense because stone is of
course what the surface is made of so it
makes sense to etch into stone to
reflect this stream field and so I went
through this pretty heavy
experimentation phase of and I have a
bunch of samples back in the back if you
didn't have a chance to see him check
them out later you're welcome to touch
him I went through about 40 different
types of stone to determine what their
properties were when I asked them with
the water jet and the people who at Omax
that have the water jet we're just like
what what are you doing like why would
you do that
and so this is a Dassault this last one
here was a slate so it shatters a whole
bunch the basalt kind of blows out a
quartzite produces a really nice sort of
pattern I was really happy with that one
but no one had really etched stone
before with the water jet at least two
documented like I had so so I had to go
through this heavy duty materials
experiment and after the experimentation
phase I started you know shaping it I
started working with the code to in open
frameworks to map the meteorite
locations and their sizes into edge
patterns for the water jet and so you
can see here the way the meteorite the
way the meteorite spread here this is
the Sudan impact the meteors came in and
dropped down from this side drop down
these little bits the smaller pieces and
then you know kerplunk larger larger
larger and then this is the mass of the
left over the leftover stones and so
this one really looks like something you
know like a meteor coming down and looks
like this fireball and it came down like
this because it came down it is a really
acute angle and not such a direct impact
and then I'd worked with the refinement
stage maybe metal mass to help me cut
the materials and finally develop these
three three prints so I have four
different strewn fields from four
different datasets from four different
impact sites that Peter provided to me
and these are really the only four data
sets they seemed to be existing and
that's only because we have only
recently had the technology to map these
out so this one is at Sutter's Mill in
the Sierra Nevada foothills and this one
had more of a like more of a direct
impact you don't see that kind of spread
like you didn't other ones more coming
down more like boom like that and this
stone is all sourced not locally but the
stone is as close as I could get to
match that site so you find quartzite
like this in the new mat Asiri Nevada
foothills all the time this is the
aforementioned Sudan impact and so this
is a French limestone and and with this
you get these kind of really kind of
crazy unpredictable pockety kind of
patterns these sort of modeled patterns
that happens because the water is water
instant predictable and then this is the
meteorite impact at chellah been scanned
in Russia so you might have seen from
the dashboard camera several
years ago of all the fireballs going
across and this one came up from this
direction and then the big fall was over
here and so with string fields I thought
about this time model and and the sort
of physical life span of the artwork is
sort of like the present moment and and
because I've hatched into stone you know
the physical life spans are artworks
gonna be like maybe here my life span is
gonna be right around here so it's gonna
be much longer than me that that artwork
lives probably my storage space and off
to my to my various relatives and I'm
gonna present one last project and then
one last proposition and then and then
we'll go on to a question and answer
period after that so the last one I want
to talk about is hello world which is a
collaboration between planet labs and
Autodesk and it's the first art
exhibition in space right so planet labs
for those of you that aren't familiar
with it is a local company out here that
is it's a satellite company that is
launching low orbit satellites around
the world at about maybe about thirty
six of them at any one time and they
orbit very quickly and they're imaging
satellites so these are called dev
satellites they're used for applications
such as for farming for example if you
want to see your fields every day and
how they might change as opposed to
Google Maps which will give you a Google
satellite which will give you an a view
a static view this will give you a more
dynamic view and with these satellites
they're pretty small as you can see this
is not my artwork but this is someone
else's and they offer to us to laser
etch the size of the satellites and put
artwork on there all right so I thought
that was kind of a great opportunity and
as a call for entries to our community
and so what happens is once they're kind
of put out into space they open up and
the art word becomes visible and then
they put the solar panels out and so the
artwork becomes visible in space if you
were you know maybe 10 feet away from
the satellite so so we have to kind of
take it on faith that's up there and so
you know my point of being free is what
can I put in space given the canvas of
the satellites so I thought really hard
about this and making physical data
visualizations I came up with this idea
and this is what Otto's been drawing for
us for the evening it's a slightly
smaller version or a slightly more
coarse version of the same thing and
what this is is two
data visualizations of the earth so the
first one is a map of all the population
of all the cities of the world and so
you can see some of the larger cities
Tokyo over here very large so the larger
the square the larger the population
lots of lots of people in India New York
pretty big saw Paulo Rio also very big
there's London over there uh yeah
Portuguese sweets right over here and
there's a lot of empty spaces you know
in our map like not so much here
Australia's here mostly empty some some
cities over here and on the bottom is
the carbon footprint of all those cities
and so if you kind of pull that out
you see predictably the United States is
like crazy
China kind of crazy Tokyo a lot smaller
than the population of Tokyo India is
you know is actually about the same and
in Africa predictably is a lot less of
impact there's also some interesting
features like if you check out these
points like New York you know if
Shanghai has some of the cities in China
Tokyo and then Tehran and Riyadh you'll
see that that there's a huge carbon
footprint
in in the Middle East and so this is a
replica of the final edge panel this is
a was presented at an exhibition at the
Chabot space and Science Center this is
a lot larger than the smaller one and
and and what I like about this is that
the satellites are set to burn up in
Earth's atmosphere after about three
years and so it's been up there for
about two years of my artwork in space
which I cannot see will will be up there
for another year and then plunge to
aspire to death and and I love this I
thought about this really hard that this
this data visualization it's so simple
as one that the satellite view might see
but also is this kind of poetic warning
that about climate change to pay
attention to and the last proposition
I'm going to make for the evening is to
let artists be artists right so what
does that mean artists are the ones who
I believe have access to this amazing
methodology of art thinking the other
ones who who work with this methodology
all the time and and while I'd like a
lot of the books and a lot of the book
art thinking that mu Amie
Whittaker talks about her version of our
thinking in a certain way
and her ideas are amazing but the
application of our ideas are to bring
art thinking into corporation spaces and
how to train people like engineers and
people who are not artists how to think
about art from an hour thinking point of
view but but these are engineers who are
trained to do engineering and so I think
a lot of times like they have a lot of
trouble doing this they don't really do
it very well because they're they're
doing engineering work all day and then
they're asked to think like artists for
you know when they're in their spare
time it doesn't really make sense so I
would argue that it's you really want to
bring artists into these spaces and give
them that kind of economic freedom that
kind of support in corporation spaces in
funding spaces and let them make these
crazy wackadoodle projects because
artists are the ones who had that kind
of unbounded sort of ways of thinking
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Scott
[Applause]
that's great suit so let's just quit
because I think that the hash marks are
did you mention that yeah do you want to
just say so those are the hash marks on
the bottom or sort of an indicator so
this hash mark aligns with Tokyo this
one here with on the bottom bottom in
the middle aligns with London and the
one on the Left aligns with New York
City just at some points for yeah for
orientation on the Saudi do you think
that with the piece like this or some of
the others is the is the readability
sort of a kind of high level first
encounter being able to understand it
how important is that or is sort of the
disorientation of what the hell am I
looking at is is do you think of that as
being more important fair question and
it I think it's that the conversation
between legibility and aesthetics is one
that depends on the piece so something
like waterworks I felt like it's
important to have more on the legible
side and but something that you know
something like this one and if I kind of
go back just a couple of slides you know
if you look at this piece which of
course only exists in space but does
exist on the website this is legible as
a map of the world and you may not be
able to understand exactly what that
data is but when you look at it closely
you can start to get there but sometimes
sometimes the work doesn't have to be so
legible it can just be an aesthetic
experience that it doesn't really work
that way so it's really context
dependent um so we've got a I'm sure a
lot of questions out here Rio is over
here so catch her eye she's gonna get
the microphone to you I'm gonna ask a
couple more quick questions and but but
definitely free undo that and and I want
to take a moment to thank everyone all
the long now members who are listening
on our or listening and watching on the
livestream we've got members from all
over there doing that so definitely send
us your questions as well in the chat in
there and and they'll get relayed to me
on the stage so so you're you mentioned
you know new media artist is so you've
been doing like 15 years of new media
artist so you've watched a lot of that
new me
turn into old media so there's an
interesting and and I think all of us
who even just as individuals as
consumers we're all watching technology
progress and we're watching some things
come and go I mean you you've done work
in Second Life
but now you've you've been involved in
I'm sure
3d printing from early on and seeing it
change and mature and so forth what's
your take away as somebody who uses
technology and is you know now you're on
boarding new technologies are on the
horizon I'm sure you're playing around
with different things what lessons do
you take from both how things have been
promising and fallen and and how new
things are emerging on the horizon what
can you tell us I think there's sort -
there's many aspects that question I
could answer but there's two sort of
things I think about from an artistic
point of view whenever a new technology
is really introduced and made available
to artists there's this gap between when
that technology is made available and
when it sort of becomes for lack of a
better term like like sort of co-opted
into mainstream before it's really good
made establish the set of codes around
it yes during that period where artists
are often playing with that technology
and working with ways to define it and
to play with this so 3d printing is a
good example of you know working at
autodesk at their at their facilities
there we had access to these 3d printers
not a long time ago during the 3d
printing sort of revolution but rather
at a time where as being talked about
like 2013 2014 2015 and - to modern day
and suddenly with artists at having
access to use tools they're making
things that people would not have
thought about had they not been there so
by the time 2017 2018 rolls around they
have a reference point to what 3d
printing can do so instead of people
making Yoda heads you know an engineer
was doing that and putting him on like
duane going you have artists making like
much more innovative sort of you know
projects around it and we've got a
there there we go yeah I have a question
and it's a question to comment
observation I love the point you made
that art is more similar to science than
it is to design the way I've held that
my head has been in a way art and
science are constantly asking questions
whereas design is really about answering
and finding solutions but I'd like to
ask you a little bit about the
distinction between art and science
in the sense that as a system of
thinking or a form of knowledge
production both art and science are
peer-reviewed and cumulative and so
forth but there is a the interesting
difference is that art really has an
ability to ask questions unencumbered by
facts or by
unencumbered by political systems I mean
it really is one of those areas where
human beings are really allowed to
challenge assumptions and to reveal the
invisible and - and to demand answers to
questions or propose questions that are
really challenging and I would argue
that as a species given the potency of
culture and collective knowledge our
ability to actually survive on the
planet is all about our ability to ask
these questions and to push the edges
and the presence of art in every culture
is not a fact that human beings like art
but it's a fact that those cultures that
have been able to exert political power
in such a level that questions about it
are not allowed are no longer around
because adaptability requires the
ability to ask questions beyond our
framework so in a way art provides
adaptability to the species and that's
why we have it and so I'd like to you
know just sort of compliment you for
your work but also ask you to riff on
I think you you've yeah you've said it
you've very said what what I could
possibly most the things I could
possibly say that that we know that art
there's a few things like art is existed
in every human culture and the ones that
and also one thing to think about
politically repressive systems
I always clamp down on art right so I
mean we know this from like our own
system about the NEA funding and things
like that we know that about just about
every system that has a sense of like
political repression will start taking
away the artist now what do they do that
right so that's really one of the areas
to think about an answer to what you're
saying about is it it sort of takes that
adaptability out of the question
out of the framework and that's one of
the many reasons but I think yeah just
that's one thought I would sort of add
to your your what the journalists
thought you provided so what what has
been useful about having that your chart
of art thinking so you mentioned that
Amy Whitaker you know she's trying to
bring it into into business what's been
useful for you about having this to show
to people yeah so this is the first time
I presented this diagram publicly but
it's been useful for me as a process
because you know as every artist I've
had many failures and I'm getting much
better at not making failures anymore
and so one of the things with our
thinking model is that I didn't really I
kind of skipped over this in my talk was
that art thinking let's get over to it
for a second so one thing about this
model is that art thinking and we have
discoveries that there's a failure mode
that and this is what something that Amy
Whittaker talks about that any point you
can fail in this process and it's okay
to fail like if you come to the
refinement process to the stage and you
fail and you can't make and you can't
really refine the work and you kind of
mind it in mind it in mind it you just
have to let it go you just have to start
over and abandon it I've made the
process the problem of getting too
attached to the work and maybe working
under a deadline and then just kind of
pumping the work out anyways and pushing
through and then I end up with this like
kind of tepid peace it doesn't quite
work it's on my website and I look I
don't like Hajis you know why did I make
that one and and so in many cases would
be better just to
I think about each of those as failure
notes and one things that artists do is
they work towards an arc of failure and
designers work towards an art or success
so they're trying to make a successful
project and oftentimes I'm taking stuff
in that experimentation but and hoping
it will fail like like will this
hopefully fail if it fails and I can
just drop it and do something else so
let me ask you another question another
difference between scientists and
artists I was thinking about you know
scientists you know they're meticulously
documenting as they're doing their
experiments and and as a community and
as a pursuit you're not going to you
know so working with scientists you have
the benefit of seeing this variety of
heterogeneity of different approaches to
something or different experiments and
failed experiments not so much in art so
one is that is that a good thing because
you you're not encumbered by some of it
and also is a computer scientist you
know as a coder I'm sure you're you're
documenting or you're doing you're doing
some things in some ways to document
that stuff so first of all you haven't
looked at my code just go get rose repo
and you'll see how bad the coding is and
I all from the Exploratorium can attest
to that one my ex co-workers and and so
but but I think scientists document the
results they document their findings but
when I go down and steady I'm amazed at
what they actually don't talk human they
don't document all these amazing
materials that could be archived and
like made public like the spaces they
don't they don't photograph the spaces
they work they don't really think about
the stuff they think about like the
datasets the results and so they're
documenting this small sliver and
artists their documentation is really
their work in some ways and so you know
when you're making artwork gallerist
i've worked with and other artists are
very careful about about like you know
working with archival ink you know and
using the white gloves and packing
everything just so and and they're
always you know those are always a
question this archival ink is this how
is this made how is that made and so
that's really the documentation we work
in and I think in a lot of ways artists
actually are better at archiving their
process in their work than
scientists and artists are also you know
competing for like these sort of
sequestered spaces a lot of times and
one of the things to think about is and
my conversations Peter is that he would
talk about how the journals in which he
published would have a very very small
audience like you know ten scientists or
twenty scientists and artists even
showing in galleries I might have a
relatively small audience but it's ten
times what you might get for a
world-class scientist and so our
documentation in those spaces are much
different than what you might get in
like a space like Drake is working on
which reaches millions of people how
well does Drake document is really the
question to ask we've got a question
back here with the mic so I really loved
how you framed your work and how you
describe the scientific process versus
the artistic process and then you have
your propositions where you you said let
artists be artists
so I guess my question is I feel like
you're describing two threads which is
like art as a verb either known as a
process or art as a as a noun as an
identity and for you and your work and
how you think about that in relation to
time what do you privilege the artistic
identity or the artistic process and how
would you sort of delineate the two or
not Wow good question um yeah there's
definitely slippage of terms there and I
don't think I could privilege one term
or the other I mean when I introduce
myself I'm just myself as an artist and
that's what my identity is so if I'm on
a plane with someone that's my my
identity they ask me what I'm doing and
that's that's my professional identity
through the world but I mean they
operate in different spheres I guess
those just one is the one is the now and
identity sphere another as a process
based fear but I think if I had just
really make a determine if I had to drop
one I'd drop the identity and just go
with the process to me that process
based approach is something that's far
more natural I mean I learned when I was
in college when I actually was on a
science track to do organic chemistry
and things like that and I started
cheating and baking my lab reports and
and writing these really
you tailed fake lab reports about all
the crazy things that would happen in
the experiments I realized really
quickly that the artistic process or
like the telling story process was much
more interesting to me than the
scientific process and so this was
inherent in like my being at a figure
the young age to tell stories to you
know stretch things out and not really
pay as much attention to but also have
respect for the scientific process so
and we'll we'll take more questions from
the audience
let's talk for another second about
another project that study Frank is here
and we'll talk about Frank in a second
but what are you guys collaborating on
with your other study for us again
you're you're currently it's Eddie right
does that run through the end of the
year or what's gonna run for a while
longer um you know like a lot of things
we're not sure about the exact bounds of
the project heart doesn't it here two
calendars yeah and so the current
project I'm working on with Frank is
we're making a stellar map and so the
stellar map is a map of the exoplanets
in our in our nearby system or nearby
galaxies and my thinking of the current
thinking about this collaboration I
haven't run this by Frank yet so he'll
learn about it right now which is that
I'm thinking about making a map of just
the ones that are habitable the ones
that have more water on them than other
ones so not kind of ignoring the gas
giants and making just like these nodes
of possible exploration and so thinking
about making this as an installation
that's physical as opposed to a virtual
installation and having people going
through space and having it activated
some sort of sound component and that's
currently where that's at that's in
development of a few months and
Franklin's come up for first like real
quick so Frank is actually gonna speak
for us in 2018 he's a astronomer at SETI
I'm gonna hand you the mic and do you
want to just tell us I don't know first
of all you can tell us that he's totally
wrong or what happens anything on that
and and and maybe you can say word
actually about what from a scientist
perspective what it's like collaborating
with an artist and then we can talk
about what's going to happen after the
talk briefly - hi sorry but we started
working together like what
so continent Li is located nearby my gym
so I'm after the idea was that we had
long conversations in fact we met values
times and the project is changing but
ideally what I wanted to express as a
scientist is that we scientists are
trying to explore the world we are
astronomer define finding new exoplanets
planets around stars which are a bit of
all or could be available and I noticed
that people have a hard time to
understand the distance to understand
where are those planets so our
collaboration is basically is gonna be
the guy who's gonna make this map and
make us realise the distance between
those exoplanet but also make us realize
that in fact some of them are very very
close and one day in the future my idea
is we will go there so this we could be
the first map of that that will show the
people that yes there is a bit about
their world's over there and maybe there
is life and that's why we work at the
SETI Institute so that's our project but
in terms of working at the SETI
Institute and having artists I mean this
has been kind of a game changer for a
lot of us science is very dry it's a
very dry environment sometimes you know
you talk to your colleagues about papers
as being refused or grants that you need
not get sometimes you talk about some
great discoveries you've made but
ultimately when you talk between
scientists is not very motivating and
having people like you coming to this
Institute this and this out is to come
with some great ideas who come with this
question that we don't realize people
how has being extremely entertaining but
also extremely useful for us to to
realize that yeah we do some cool stuff
and something that Peter told me is that
he likes the fact that you ask him about
these fragments coordinates and for
Amy's like yes the bunch of data but for
you it was something more it was
something that tangible that you could
use for you for you out and
he was very excited and you know a peter
is right it doesn't care it doesn't care
and then suddenly when you cares about
what you're doing he send you probably
like twenty more that that would ask you
to to do but we he was amazing because
Peter you know I asked him to show up to
the the show the opening last year when
you present this and he's like I'm not
sure if I'm gonna show up and then and
then and then he shows up like an hour
before the show and the gallery's not
even open yet and he has this I get
there he has this box full of meteorites
right so Jana and I said at the gala
roast and I set up a table for him in
the back and so he was just showing his
meteorites to like the people who came
to this show and it was like I was like
stop doing that you're taking away from
the works just kidding it was amazing
though it's just amazing to me to have
this steady scientist inside this
completely unfamiliar art space in the
Mission District in San Francisco and
Peter just had the biggest smile on his
face he was just completely in his
element and and all the people there
just loved and loved talking to him and
you know love touching them with gloves
and and really enjoying that experience
so Frank do you want to so you brought a
prototype
telescope here and work in it well no
well just I'm just gonna let them we'll
get back into it but just so just look
for Frank
afterwards it won't be right immediately
afterwards we're gonna bring out here
but then Frank's gonna scout out of
place and come back and let us know and
he's ready right and we'll we'll take
you think it's it's not gonna happen
okay
well then will you you'll hang out and
people can can can drink and commiserate
with you and you'll tell them more about
how it works
yeah okay okay so look for this man
afterwards so thank you Frank
[Applause]
so Scott that's a great segue do you
want to say something about the SETI
artists and residents program in general
just a little bit of background about
that and Charles Lindsay and started the
program several years ago and and the
backstory is that he was in he can tell
it much better than I am so I'm gonna
try to summarize what I remember and we
should actually in case I don't think
we've actually said anything other than
steady so do you wanna the search for
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence hopefully everyone here
knows what they do so they're looking
and searching for extraterrestrial life
and they're doing it in a few different
ways in our solar system outside of our
solar system through listening and then
through observation such as Kepler and
through what Frank's doing and which is
adaptive optics using telescopes so so
kind of really three ways three primary
ways of looking for life so collecting
possible biological samples and then
listening and looking and and so they're
sort of like this friendly race on is
the way I've seen it between the three
different vectors and so the the city
artist-in-residence program came about
because Charles Lindsey was giving a
talk and Jill tarter from who sort of
she was based on Jodie Foster's
character from contact was based on her
we're at the same event and they had a
conversation and and hatched this idea
of having a residency program and so
like Frank said bringing artists into
the space so that they can give
scientists an insight to why their work
is so amazing and for artists it's
amazing to have access to these
scientists who are normally you know you
never have access to these are just
amazing thinkers and so I'm actually on
the second round of artisan residents
there's about three or four or four or
five of us on this round and then
presumably there would be another round
in 2018 or so and Rachel Sussman is a
former speaker there's also been a ours
there I think we've got a question in
the back there
great listen and hold the make sure hold
the mic pretty close to you thank you
for the talk thank you Scott great talk
you have me thinking about all kinds of
things but I'll try to Center on one
question which is about the model and
I'm thinking as someone who also works
in the arts and works
support artists how we as society can
support new media artists in their
practice differently than how we've
supported artists in the past or and you
could think about this from a teaching
perspective or support perspective so
like what stages in this process need
more time like how is it different to be
working in new media I have ideas about
what that might look like but I'm
curious to hear from you yeah what the
process looks like in terms of time and
where we need to to spend time you think
you more like artists versus new media
artists or more like where we should
yeah I'm thinking of like so like a
painter might need less time to
experiment presumably because their
medium is defined they're already
working in a defined space on the canvas
and so they can spend more time shaping
and refining for example roughly yeah
but a new media artist is working more
broadly across materials yeah and in all
fairness I've developed this model you
know thinking about new media artists
and hopefully it can apply to to more
the traditional arts as well and I think
that except with new media and
technology you always have this problem
of working with the technology because
the technology itself can be really hard
to harness so you don't want to again
it's really not a good situation to get
into working something really tech heavy
at the early stages so you want to get
more tech heavy in the later stages so
like I said the tweets and space project
and we didn't really write any code
until I mean besides this little like
silly Arduino test and tell the showing
face like we didn't really get there
till the very end until we got the
funding until we really were ready to
show it and so deferring that that kind
of technological investment for the new
media artist seems to be the way to go
and so for me trying to spend a lot of
time in that experimentation cycle is
super important and trying not to rush
it into like a shaping or refinement
form and and really trying to make sure
that you you spend time experimenting
and then you do something else you do
another project you go on vacation you
give us some rest and so a lot of times
the failures I've had an artwork tend to
be from trying to make something on too
tight a deadline being really excited
about something and rushing
through it and not really thinking about
how well it's working so giving a lot of
space to a project like months and
months of space as opposed to a month of
space but I think that's kind of like
the technology is the technology bit is
as you know from we've worked together
is something that I always think about
like oh jeez do I really want to make
like a motor with this little gear
system that does this and this and this
that's gonna take me a really long time
and trying to get out of that
prototyping stage all right well this is
great as always at the interval now that
the talks over we invite you to hang out
Scott's going to be here to keep the
conversation going with him
Frank's here and he's got the the
prototype and his laptop to show you
what what it can do and this is this is
when those those final moments when when
a few more things can come together as
we keep talking let's have a big round
of applause for Scott that's really
fantastic
[Music]